what's going on there's citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
bad batch episode 11. look even though
we weren't big fans of the last couple
episodes we always go in with an
optimistic attitude are we gonna get
Cody are we gonna get rex on you doesn't
matter look we just want enjoyable Star
Wars and I feel like you know what last
few episodes I believe in the force so I
am alone with the force
and the Force is with me
um yes Jackie Chan said that yeah sure
did
um guys listen if you like satirical
racism jokes be sure to subscribe also
leave a like today that would be amazing
follow my dewy friend here Michael
tesler uh on multi-house.io
and let's let's there's a patreon but
who cares let's just watch this
Dewey
it's my favorite Star Wars character
it's not hard to imagine Harrison Ford's
saying that either
Harrison Ford was a carpenter yes he was
just like Jesus
I remember Jason segelberg
give him some audio to sync
what are they retrieving
unless you we're still here
on board I'm watching the wrong episode
I was like what the
[Laughter]
I've never seen that before
Adam metamorphosis
good title it's a lot of syllables
oh
[Music]
kinda looks carillion
foreign
spooky yeah I like this
ready for Sigourney Weaver to pop out
yeah oh Republic Commando okay
[Music]
I wonder if it's like a Jedi or
something
nope I don't think so man I'm not a Jedi
[Applause]
wow
yeah it is pure alien yeah
Sigourney Weaver was actually in the
suit
name it prove yourself
I believe we might be going to the Clone
facilities welcome doctor
all preparations have been made for your
arrival have the cargo taken below the
cargo Ellie
[Music]
yeah we're we're tying right into the
Mandalorian here didn't they go here in
season two foreign
[Music]
destroyed my civilization excuses
know that your research remains intact
it'll now serve a higher purpose
the emperor's purpose his voice is so
familiar know that I'll be taking over
operations here on Tantus and I can do
far worse than confine you to a cell
tickle you to death
that would do it for me
interesting
prime minister he remains an imperial
custody on Coruscant
here I wish to speak to him personally
cargo asset two things they refer to
when talking about grogu in season one
of Mandalorian oh my gosh is grogu the
monster in this I got a tip on a
down ship which means cargo ripe for the
taking I'll even give you 30 to the cut
that is our standard percentage
hahaha
okay 40. fine 50
as a token of my Goodwill that you seem
to have forgotten such a pain in the ass
what makes you think we'd come back at
all don't test me bandanna just get it
done
God could be problematic considering
what she knows about us
choose a diplomatic solution
this one last mission for her or a
killer but actually and spun Dakota
indication of what caused it to crash
limited Intel
there's a surprise how hard could
scavenger cargo be
oh my God what if the bad batch is what
helps Kroger
Escape
what do you mean
well we're still trying to figure out
how did grogu I mean somebody
well I'm just saying we're in the right
we have all the right pieces let's see
what the share says before we get too
excited here
the crashed vessel appears mostly intact
the cargo aboard should be in fair
enough condition to transport
[Music]
but it would be cool
thank you just say it would be cool but
the crew aboard most likely perished we
don't know for sure it
could be treasure in here
wow this is straight up the aliens
episode where is everyone
Zillow Beast something oh
unfortunate happened here it doesn't
look like Roku
word
kind of clone a Zillow beast and clone
wars and it's not warranted I will be
fine
oh
I like this it's like Nerf nuggets it'd
be cool if you're right
[Music]
yeah that was Palpatine's last order on
Coruscant
[Music]
wreck those thighs you're at the gym
why is it so cold in here it's some kind
of Suicide Squad Tech find anything on
the bridge still rerouting the reserve
power
stand by the grid should be restored the
mentality
a bad feeling about this
oh that's a cool shot damn now they pull
that off that's a second rich
what were they keeping in here oh it's
the Zillow Beast you think so for sure
yeah
Palpatine requested and make a clone of
it
[Laughter]
is back away
slowly
I'm still waiting for a clearer shot
Michael's skin
hahaha
I hope oh it's so cute I love it
it's like when there's a demogorgon then
there's a demo dog you know that's
exactly it it's a little baby
I love this episode
it's good thing all these lights are on
I suspect this is some type of research
vessel we know and whatever researching
just got loose and it's headed your way
whoa what if they kill off Tech
I've been saying it all season
oh
oh it's creepy man say I love that it
eats electricity
oh it makes it stronger yeah
still not gonna do it
not even close
damn oh it's on the loose we have to
neutralize it before it hurts anyone how
given the fact that the crew was most
likely eaten by the creature I doubt it
is currently
[Music]
love that reaction I can help I know my
way around kamino and tea go
go Rebecca me
you guys Gotta Be Heroes I mean like
they still haven't explicitly said it
and it would be a very baby little one
but that makes sense with how much time
they've had to grow it yeah no I think
you're right sure there's a great payoff
to that one episode when people thought
that would be the zoo
yeah definitively not yeah
[Music]
oh man
no I mean it took like
half of the Jedi Grand Council that was
much more developed
yep that's my feelings
it's me at the snack bar it was
unaffected by our Blaster fire this
confirms that the species feeds on
energy which propels its rapid growth
you mean it'll get even bigger oh yeah
creature is the
must not let it get near the power grid
or it will increase color what it is say
it
this poor Planet
it's like a combo there of Godzilla and
Kong uh I'm so ready for this
damn is it all coming back to the Zillow
Beast
it's all connected Greg no I mean like
the the Empire's showing up you know
well they're clearly here to protect the
citizens yes
come on
come on now and
so are those Imperial gunships now is
that the phrase
oh man oh man you guys gotta stab it
[Music]
oh oh look at Tech protecting her
oh yeah good luck
tractor beam tractor
you guys not attracted me okay now it's
they use the Cannons previously to get
it off planet to Coruscant
yes
you need a lot more of those though or
not I guess they're upgraded the clock
it's a Pixar reference
it's taking it let's not be next
[Music]
we gotta draw the empire into the city
then we can escape well they gotta get
techno Mega
be calm we're here to protect you
we're with the government and we're here
to help
[Music]
going on a roller coaster
sometimes when you jump to light speed
terrifying
[Music]
oh yeah you saw too much
cat the Empire sucks I know
but
he had a business to run
it's good to see both sides you know
vessel was part of an imperial cloning
operation the Empire cloned the Zillow
Beast yes and finally said I suspect the
empire did not destroy the city's El
Camino to end cloning
they merely wanted to control it hmm
yes move everything send the data to
Echo and Rex
see what they can find out ah it's all
coming together
Rex gonna have a field there
Echo oh yeah I'm over that yeah we're
cool we're cool
again no harm no foul yeah
the creature has been recovered and is
now safely secured below
good
and our other guest the shuttle is
arriving now
the Prime Minister the cooperation of
your Chief scientist has not been
forthcoming it must be frustrating to
have your resources but lack the
expertise to achieve your goals you're
telling me
I fear you misunderstand your situation
here there is a particular clone you
must locate a young girl oh the key to
controlling
how very interesting it
discuss
good thing they're looking for that ship
man
where's Benny
[Laughter]
okay
that was great so glad Zillow Beast is
back uh
so glad that all this cleaning stuff is
getting tied in together I mean this is
like a perfect uh through line to the
Mandalorian and then subsequently the
creation of snoke and subsequently the
creation of Palpatine 2.0 you could call
it that it's like
0.3 the one from Rise of Skywalker yeah
yeah he's great yeah it's great my
favorite Palpatine them all in inmate
his best interpretation of the character
uh yeah yeah somehow Palpatine returned
and now we know that it's all Omega the
dead speaks the dead speak uh
okay okay so yeah they gotta get Omega
then yeah considering the progress that
we know of the future of how things
progress unless of course now let's say
comes in and it's like there's another
way to achieve your goals that does not
involve
Omega
which would be boring that would be
really boring yeah no they have to go
after Omega
um but this the Zillow Beast has never
come back
in other things right no not yet
um no I mean I think all of this it
plays into the larger like if there is
which I'm uh showrunners Catherine
Kennedy have said there is a cinematic
climactic event that we're working
towards right now
um and this is they also mentioned that
Mandalorian season four is going to be
actually a middle chapter of something
bigger yes uh which like as we play into
the thrawn Ahsoka you know that whole
careless
who gives a about it I love it's
okay
boring Bridger is a wonderful Ezra
Miller is a fantastic actor yeah I agree
I think having I think Ezra Miller
playing Ezra pressure was the right
choice yeah I was surprised including
the Clone version of Ezra there's three
of them
let's keep it on track yeah yeah no no I
think yeah I think you're right about
all that and I but more importantly more
than what it ties into more than what it
connects it was actually just a good
episode it was a solid episode it had a
great spooky sense I feel like every
sci-fi thing I ever watched at one point
or another will have an inevitable
episode in a season that goes this is
like alien this is like the Alien movies
yeah those were good and full of dread
that's spooky ominous Horror in there
and it's it's apt when it comes to the
Zillow Beast uh something that I I've
never I've only seen Clone Wars once but
so and that was a little long time ago
yeah I I just finished the fourth time
around yeah good call good call yeah no
I'm really glad uh it's paid off I had
that feeling with Zillow beasts of after
people thought it was that one creature
in that Planet episode Legend of Zelda
looking like yeah
people thought that was a civil obese
and uh so after it wasn't I went all
right I'm gonna write off a Zillow Beast
returning completely so I didn't even
answer my Noggin
however the way it came back I thought
it was really suspenseful yeah and
spooky and the way they would always
check in with it and watching it grow
and how it also Rift not just on alien
but like Kaiju movies you know I was
gonna say that was I mean I feel like
Star Wars particularly animated content
does best when it pays not so subtle uh
homages to some other great works of art
uh you know and I guess Star Wars in
general I mean it's just like let's take
Samurai movies and westerns and put them
in space yeah
um you know so yeah so that was a really
it was just a fun episode I felt like
you know uh for the 40th time both of us
were really worried that Tech was gonna
get killed
um he's great which uh yeah which means
you know they've they've set the stakes
where we need them
um now I'm really interested to see how
they're gonna start working towards the
closure of this season part of me
wonders if it's gonna end and with uh
Omega getting taken and the bad batch
needing to work with our friends in the
Clone Rebellion to try to break Omega
out and to take those two story lines
and put them together we'll see that's
my theory what do you think Greg
uh I think that she will get taken I
don't think it will end that way even
though the show would be smart to do
that that way we better get another
season that way he can't be full to go I
guess I'll watch season threes so yeah I
think it would be be a smart way but I
think they would want to bring some time
I think it'll be a little bit more I
feel like though yeah Omega will be
taken off the rest of her Tech's gonna
cry the Tech's gonna be like no I have
learned to love you Omega I care more
about you than I ever realized it's
gonna be brilliant mark my words
Crosshair is going to be the one to save
Omega
um words have been marked I think
they've cut them out of the show
they had one episode mark my words
either that or Hondo
they're gonna I think what they will end
this season with is a tease to whatever
the bigger thing is that they're
building too as alluded already with
Mandalorian season four offering up some
middle chapter to something bigger so I
think that's what they'll end with yeah
um but as far as as far as uh I was I
was just happy that we got a good bad
job I agree do you think final question
there is any like direct seeing of grogu
no I mean we're we're dealing with the
cloning facility like we're we're seeing
the origins of of all that stuff in the
Mandalore you doubt it doubt it I mean
when you look at the beginning of where
Mando started uh I think we don't know
how grogu ended up where he was but yeah
you know I think they would have already
have had they wouldn't have just lost
him into possession they wanted to pull
up metichlorians out of him right yeah
is that what they want to do yeah they
want the MCAT yeah
um yeah I love that medical orients this
thing that so many of us Star Wars fans
pushed against is now the soul creative
tissue
commit to the bit all right yeah it's
good number one no I mean yeah grogu
definitively I don't think the Empire
had him in their control
um I think they managed to locate him
somehow yeah and I want to know how yeah
and I I just I think it would be really
neat if whether through the cloned
Rebellion or through you know any one of
these
um I wonder if there's connective thread
because we still don't know I'm also
really interested to see if Jedi
Survivor is connected to this
um because there are some questions
strong cloning I mean the fella in the
back to tank in the trailer
um I'm just I have so many questions uh
and hey that means they're doing a good
job so yeah they've won you back over
yeah I mean I was never not sold Greg I
love that
I just had two episodes that were you're
a big fan of it's fine it was they're
allowed to have two not perfect episodes
and they brought it back home yeah they
brought it back home and next week we're
gonna find treasure have we hey and they
wanted to get rid of Sid we didn't even
talk about that that's a really
important I hope they do they were like
one Mission and then we're out and I
appreciate that the writers figured out
how annoying Sid was and then came up
with a a narrative reason that they're
worried that Sid would turn on them and
give up their yeah to the which is so
fair to justify why they would still
kick it with her yeah again I liked your
idea though just kill her just kill her
I think that would be great then you
could do season three the evil batch
yeah what did you guys think I would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments I will respond I do want room
one thing I have to say yeah the the the
doctor yeah I don't know who this voice
actor was I played him how have we seen
him before you know I was trying to
figure that out because he said he's
Hemlock was it yeah I think so yeah it's
such a striking presence yeah it wasn't
really striking presence I mean I think
and we're more than likely going to see
a young
an intern version of uh what's his name
uh Dr Pershing Pershing yeah yeah uh
from Mandalorian
um yeah that's that's what I was hoping
for and then I was doing math in my head
and I was like all right I see why
um but yeah no it it's um I I didn't
recognize him uh but that doesn't mean
he hasn't shown up in a book or
something yeah I like them a lot I think
I like the more soft-spoken sincere the
ones where they don't play it evil like
yeah I could see you pal people would
trust you yeah I feel like that's just
an issue with the empire in general
which is what I like about this whole
sub plot that's going on is sure this is
almost more nefarious and more
interesting and and I think just like
bring back like the former prime
minister whose people were all
annihilated and then just like I love
what they're doing
um oh one more thing
um
every pixel might Baker I want to get to
know you better for 2023 yeah so I'm
gonna ask you five questions and I want
you to give five sentences only you
cannot give more than that yeah and I
want you to answer me this one
how many serious relationships have you
been in yeah and like serious like
you know could it be the one yeah good
good emphasis two if you were to be a
donut which donut would you prefer to be
three and and that just has it whatever
your choice is we understand it has
nothing to do with your sexuality just
like I appreciate emphasis
three
if you saw the ending of the movie
sausage party would you have
participated as a human being with the
food four yeah that's an easy answer
yeah yeah I'll judge you if you give the
wrong one four
um
what religion do you belong to and which
religion do you really not like and five
do you prefer Jeremy johns or Chris
stuckman
for the religion one
good question
thanks for being here Everett we love
you Everett thank you for your support
[Music]
foreign